hey everyone
welcome to this week's live session
today's topic
is become a front-end developer but
before we begin
i'd like to thank our viewers for tuning
in and actively participating in these
sessions
let's wait for a while for more people
to tune in
also we have a dedicated team to answer
all your queries
so if you have any questions let us know
in the chat section
we'll get back to you
all right i see a few more people
so this session will be about today's
topic which is
become a front-end developer so let us
begin
we are going to discuss the things you
need to know to become a web developer
first we will start with basic skills
which every web developer
must know before moving into more
advanced web
frameworks then we will understand what
react is
and why it is so popular after that we
will go through another web framework
called
angular then we will also get to know
about a comparatively new front-end
framework
called vue in the end we will go through
the front-end developer salary trends
which will give you an insight of the
job market
so without further ado let's get started
first the basic skills let us understand
what basic skills are required to become
a
web developer there are a few
recommendations
in that you must learn for either path
these are the common things
every programmer should know the first
one
is the github so git is a free
open source version control system that
enables collaborations in a particular
project
it is designed to handle both small and
large scale projects
git is a tool used to save code and
create different versions to better
manage the feature updates
in the product or an application so
followed by the github the next
important thing we have is the data
structures and algorithms
a data structure is the location used to
store and organize
data an algorithm is a collection of
steps
to solve a particular problem learning
data structures and algorithms
allow us to write efficient and fast
computer programs
so followed by data structures and
algorithms we have the text
editor get familiar with the text editor
of your choice
visual studio code is the top choice for
most of the web developers and my
personal choice too
because of the large support of
languages and of course
the speed the text editor is where you
write all your code and the terminal is
where you execute it
so followed by the text editor we have
the command line
the command line is an important tool to
get familiar with
it is how you run your code after
writing it on a text editor
the better you are on the command line
the more efficient you'll be as
developer so followed by the command
line we have the http and https
the http protocol is the backbone of the
internet
it handles requests and responses from a
web application
it is mandatory for a web developer to
have good knowledge of
both http and https in order to build
fast and responsive web applications now
that we know what basic skills are
required to become a front-end developer
let's discuss about the most popular
front-end library that has to react
now what exactly react is
so react is a front-end javascript
library used for building beautiful user
interface components
it is an open source meaning it can be
used in your commercial projects
without any restrictions it is also
component based and these components can
be used again
and again promoting core reusability
it is an mvc or model view controller
architecture
react is the v responsible for how
the application looks and feels for the
end user
now why should you learn react react has
always been in high performance as it
uses
virtual dom rather in real
dom so basically dom stands for
document object model and is used by
every internet browser for rendering a
web page or an application
react can also be easily integrated with
other javascript frameworks like
node.js resulting in the development of
a completely
new web application including front end
and the back end
it is comparatively easy to maintain
large scale applications written in
react because
it highly promotes code reusability and
code
readability so followed by react
the next important thing we have is the
angular
we have an idea of what react is but it
is not the only framework used for
building
user interfaces so now let us know about
angular
so now what exactly angular is angular
unlike react is a fully fledged
framework for web application
development
which usually does not require
additional libraries for implementing
additional functionalities like routing
it is also open source and backed by
google and as regularly updated
resulting in
constantly improved performance and
addition of new features
in terms of performance it was begged to
be much slower than react but
with the recent versions performance
seems to be on par with react
now why should you learn angular angular
is one of the most
stable frameworks out there it is also
the most complete meaning you don't have
the need to integrate with
other frameworks since it's pretty much
includes everything for the web
development
of a complete web application
angular backed by google is safe choice
for using in long-term projects since it
is not going anywhere
anytime soon angular is obviously used
by google for its web applications and
also used by
other large-scale companies creating a
lot of job opportunities
now followed by angular the next one we
have is the view
now that we know quite a bit about the
two popular front-end frameworks namely
react and
angular let's now go ahead into view and
learn
a bit more about vue.js library
now what exactly is view
view is a lightweight and open source
progressive javascript framework
used for developing interactive web user
interfaces
it is meant to be integrated with other
libraries to develop a complete
web application like react vue.js is
mainly focused on the view part of the
web application and
hence it's bit faster when compared to
angular
which is a complete web application
solution
view.js is commonly referred to as view
and pronounced as vue.js or view is
rightly so now why should you learn vue
any beginner web developer can easily
understand view and start building their
own
web user interfaces
like react view also uses virtual dom
resulting in better performance and it
also uses the component-based code
design
promoting core reusability and code
readability
vue.js has become popular in recent
times and many companies are starting to
use it
owing to its lightweight performance and
easy integration with other web
libraries and frameworks
now with this let's move into the next
section where we will discuss about the
front-end developer
salary trends now that we know what
skills we need to become a front-end
developer
let's now have a look into the salarians
of a front-end developer
front-end developers are always in high
demand since new web applications are
launched and managed continuously
there are generally offered generous
salaries across the globe
the salaries also depend on the factors
like frameworks
skills and the work experience the
average salary of a front-end developer
in
india is 5 lakh 6 000 rupees per annum
the average salary of a front-end
developer in united states is
76 929 us dollars
per annum there you go we have discussed
possibly everything about becoming a
front-end developer
and we have a youtube playlist that
covers everything from the basics of
html and css
to advanced web development frameworks
don't forget to check those out if you
are interested in front-end development
or web development in general
the links are added in the description
box below and with that
we have reached to the end of this video
hope you liked it
think we missed anything important let
us know in the live chat or in the
comment section below if you're watching
this
later thank you for watching and stay
tuned for more from
simply learn
you